it's inappropriate to tell a
kindergartener uh that their gender is a
choice it's inappropriate to tell a
second grader that they may have been
born in the wrong body now California
has that uh they want to have that
injected into the elementary school it's
also important to respect parental
rights to know what curriculum is being
used in the classroom and everything
should be age appropriate I actually
have something that I brought that some
parents have objected to so this is a
book that's in some of the schools in
California Florida this is not
consistent with our standards called
gender queer I it's some of it's blacked
out you would probably be able to put
this on air this is pornography it's
cartoons it's aimed at children uh and
it's wrong so this should not be in
schools uh when people like on the left
say that somehow you're Banning books by
removing this from a young kid's
classroom no this is not age appropriate
and so we're going to stand for the
rights of parents I think we need to do
that Nationwide I don't think you can
have a situation where some states just
trample on the rights of parents parents
have a fundamental right to direct the
education and upbringing of their kids I
mean